نظاره اب الحديث الساعه حول العالم
والاراء حولها متضاربه والتفاصيل الكامله
لشهاده الامير هاري في المحكمه وكريم
بنزيما اتحادي اهلا بكم
مؤتمر ابل السنوي نقدر نلخص فيه النظاره
اللي صارت حديث الناس وحسستنا انه نحن
انتقلنا للمستقبل فالنظاره اللي كنا
بنشوفها في الافلام وشفنا شي بيشبهها في
احدى حلقات مسلسل الخيال العلمي بلاك
ميرور اللي كسر الدنيا على نتفليكس من
سنوات واللي كنا بنفكر انه لو حنشوفها
حقيقه يعني مو الان هذه النظاره ابل خلتها
حقيقه والان كمان ابل كشفت خلال مؤتمرها
السنوي في كاليفورنيا عن نظاره فيجن برو
بتجمع بين الواقع الافتراضي والحقيقه
النظاره قيل انها حائزه على 5000 براءه
اختراع وتقدر تلبسها وتتحكم من خلالها بكل
شيء حوالينك شاشات مكالمات كمبيوتر وغيرها
من خلال الاوامر الصوتيه وحركه العين
واليد وحتكون متاحه للبيع السنه القادمه
في الولايات المتحده وطبعا اعلان زي هذا
وكما هو بسهم ابل اللي ارتفع وسجل رقم
قياسي جديد للمره الاولى من 17 شهر
النظاره الكثار حتى مو فاهمين بالضبط
بالضبط يعني ايش فايدتها كان فيها جانب
اخر صادم للناس
مميزاتها فالسعر عمل بلبله ليه لانها
ببساطه بثلاثه الاف وخمسميه دولار وردت
فعلا حاضرين في المؤتمر لحظه الاعلان عن
سعرها عكست لحد كبير رده الفعل على هذا
الموضوع لاحقا على المنصات
النظاره فعليا عامله ضجه يعني مو بس بعالم
التكنولوجيا والاعمال والاسهم فعلى
المنصات الناس حول العالم شغلها الشاغل
الساعات الماضيه نظارات ابل وبصراحه
النظاره تحولت لماده دسمه للميمز والنكت
ان كان بسبب سعرها ولا العالم كيف حيصير
بسببها ولا التعليقات على مارك ذكر فالناس
اعتبرت انه يعني ابل سبقت متى في عالم
النظارات
لايك
[تصفيق]
على جنب نظاره ابل فعليا عامله انقسام بين
الناس والاراء حولها متضاربه جدا في عاشقي
التكنولوجيا اللي مبهورين ومبسوطين فيها
جدا وشايفينها الثوره في هذا العالم وفي
المعترضين وهذول منهم اللي
شايفينولوجي كبير والعالم لسه مو مستعد له
وفي طبعا اللي شايف السعر فلكي معانا من
سانهزيف في كاليفورنيا الصانع المحتوى
التقني فيصل السيف اهلا فيك معانا يا فيصل
اول شيء كيف الجو عندك
مساكم الله بالخير
الجو جميل الله يسعدكم يا رب مساك الله
بالخير متابعيني جميل والامور حلوه جميل
جدا انت من المبهورين كمان بموضوع النظاره
ولا شايف انه لا
العليم من الملتزمين في هذا الامر
الواقع الافتراضي اتابعه تقريبا من حوالي
15 سنه وبالتالي الموضوع مره جديد ولكن
يبين لكم قوه قبل من ناحيه التكنولوجيه
وايضا ماركتين تسويقيه بشكل جدا كويس ايوه
طيب فانت بتقول انه الموضوع ما هو جديد
طيب اذا الموضوع ما هو جديد ايش سر
الهستيريا العامه اللي صايره على الموضوع
جميل جدا الحين تكلمنا على السعر فهو
بالفعل السعر حق المطورين اللي متاح له
النظارات المرحله الاولى من اين
ظهر بتقنيه جديده من شركتكم بسعر مره
مرتفع
بهذا السعر المرتفع وحتى ترى متى لها
مرتفع هذا الجانب نعم من المستخدمين دائما
في اي مؤتمر لابل دائما يشوفوا السعر على
اساس انه كيف اشتري بس اشتري تليفونات
والكلام ده كله الكل يصير ابيع كليه ابيع
مدري ايش اوكي بس
جدا كثيره ولكن تكلم على فئه جديده حتى
تطبيقات متوقع نفس المنصه النظاره
تطبيقاتها
زي باقي النظارات حتى البرامج التطبيقات
غاليه يعني هذه
يعني خلينا نقول صريحين اللي حيشتروها
المهوسين بالتكنولوجيا واللي حابين
يتفشخروا
اين نقدر نقول اوكي هذا نقدر نقول استيت
منك انت بس
اول شيء اول شيء دائما في مجموعه معينه
اللي ما يستخدموها بسوروا فيها اوكي بس
طيب بس مين هي معموله لمين يعني
الفئه هذه الاولى لو تلاحظوا انه اسمها
حتى الجوالات وفي منها فحيكون في نسخه
مخففه حسب التوقعاتي حتكون السنه الجايه
تطرح فالحين المطورين واصحاب الاعمال
البزنس يقدروا يستفيدوا منها بانهم
يتبنوها ويحاولوا يطوروا فيها تطبيقات
واشياء منظوميه منها يجيبوا ربح ضخم مجنون
فوق ما تتصوروا بان اتيحت المنصه من ابل
لاول مره في تاريخه منصه تتاح فرص كثيره
للاعمال تطرحه للافراد المطورين ابدا مو
من المستخدمين وابدا مول الفشخره واصلا
شكل الواحد حيكون غريب شوي فيها طيب يعني
نحن الناس العاديين اللي اول شيء بندفع
3500 وما احنا ولا مطورين ما نشتري الان
يعني
لا تشتروا الحين وانت سويتيني انا فئه
المعاديه لان انا بشتري
[ضحك]
يتكلموا عنها انه لما تلبسها حتقدر انك
مثلا تكون بتصور مثلا مناسبه انت عايشها
والكلام ده كله فبيقولوا لك انه ابل
بزياده تبغانا كمان يعني احنا اولادي صرنا
ما بنعيش حياتنا لانه بنصور بالتليفون
الان حتى بالنظاره حنمشي يعني في حياتنا
هل هذا المستقبل اللي بنطلع له جميل جميل
جدا سؤالك لانه انا من واجه منظور تقني
الامر اللي شرحوه وقالوا انه تصوير ثلاثي
الابعاد من خلال النظاره بالنسبه للتقنيه
غير مقبول هذا صعبه جدا صعبه تقنيا انك
تصور ثلاثي الابعاد تقدر تصور بابعاد تقدر
تصور بنموذج محدد وايضا انهم احنا معليش
يعني انت تقعد في البيت لحالك او مع
عائلتك لابس نظاره قاعده تصور فيهم
الموضوع مو طبيعي وامر عدم وجود الحس
الطبيعي في التقنيات المل بوسه يخلي الناس
تنفر عنها مش تقرب منها لو انتوا النظاره
هذه كانت بشكل هذه النظاره وفيها الكاميرا
مدمجه وشويه اشياء قد تكون اقرب للناس بس
كونها كبيره هذا مجال جديد
يمشوا فيها يقعدوا يصوروا اصلا لما اقعد
اختبر النظارات في المكتب
[موسيقى]
بنشكرك على هذا الموضوع وان شاء الله تقضي
ايام حلوه في كاليفورنيا وترجع بالسلامه
واذا حتجرب النظاره صور لنا طبعا اكيد
حتصور صور لنا التجربه كيف والكلام هذا
كله طيب كان معنا
صانع المحتوى التقليدي فيصل الصيف شكرا لك
الامير هاري اليوم بشهاده امام المحكمه
العليا في لندن كاول فرد رفيع من العائله
المالكه بيمثل امام محكمه من 130 عام هاي
ادلب شاهدته في الدعوه اللي رافعها هو ومي
شخصيه مشهوره ضد ام جي ان اللي بتصدر صحف
ديلي ميرير
وبيتهموا فيها الشركه باختراق هواتفهم
المحموله والنشر معلومات بطريقه غير
قانونيه هاري كان لازم يحضر امس جلسه
المحاكمه ولكنه تغيب عنها لانه طلع متاخر
من امريكا لانه كان بيحضر عيد ميلاد بنته
بعيدها ثاني الاميره طيب دفاع ام جي ان
قالوا انه غيابه كان مو عادي والقاضي كمان
اندهش من عدم حضوره الجلسه طيب مثل ما
قلنا هذه من 100 شخصيه رافعه القضيه لكنه
واحد من اربعه بس راح يشهدوا امام المحكمه
وشاهدتم مستمره للساعات اليوم وبكره كمان
مكمله استجواب وراح يتم من قبل محاميين
وهو ومن قبل محامين عن المؤسسه الصحفيه
الاكيد الان وللكل يبغى يعرفه هو تفاصيل
شهاده الامير واللي بتغطي 33 مقال هو
مقدمهم بيقولوا ان المؤسسه الصحفيه حصلت
على المعلومات اللي فيهم عنه بشكل قانوني
شهاده الامير كانت من خمسه وخمسين صفحه
وبعدها بدات الاسئله والاستجواب وملخص
اللي قالوا امام المحكمه ممكن اقول لكم هو
انه هو قال بدايه انه هو رافع دعوه على
الشركه لانها حصلت على معلومات عنه بطريقه
غير قانونيه وقال انه هو طول حياته كان
بيشعر انه في انتهاك لحياته الخاصه من
الصحافه الصفراء وانه في كل علاقاته ان
كان صداقه او علاقه عاطفيه وفي الجيش وحتى
في علاقته بالعائله كانت دائما في طرف
ثالث هو الصحافه الصفراء وهذا الشيء سبب
لولو للاطراف الاخرى المعنيه
متواصله يعني كده حاله من الذعر والخوف
الامير قال كمان انه قراره بالتنحي عن
واجباته الملكيه لعب في دور كبير التطفل
ومضايقات الصحافه اللي اثرت بشكل كبير على
حالته النفسيه والعقليه هاجم الامير كمان
هاري الاعلامي الشهير بيرسمورجن اللي كان
رئيس تحرير لصحيفه ديلي ميرور اللي هي من
بين الصحف المعنيه بالدعوه واللي معروفه
عنه بيهاجم دائما هاري وزوجته ومن الاشياء
اللافته في شهاده حديثه عن تاثير الصحافه
السلبي في حياه امه الراحله الاميره ديانا
وكمان قال انه هو ما رفع الدعوه علشان وبس
لكن لانه بيشعر انه كعضو حتى لو انه هو
عضو غير عامل في العائله المالكه وكعسكري
ايضا في الجيش فعليه مسؤوليه فتح اي نشاط
اجرامي بيتم تحت مسمى الاهتمام بالراي
العام وبعيدا عن مضمون الشهاده فمن
الاشياء اللافته اللي نقلها الصحفيين
حاضرين للجلسه انهم اول مره بيسمعوا محامي
بيعطي تعليمات للمتحدثين في الجلسه كيف
يخاطبوا الشاهد فالمحامي شرح لهم انه
البروتوكول بيقول انه اول مره توجهوا له
كلام تخاطبوه فيك صاحب السمو الملكي بعدها
لما تخاطبوا تقدروا تقولوا الامير هاري
طيب من لندن معنا الكاتبه الصحفيه جوسيلين
ايليا اهلا فيك معانا جوسيلين طيب انا
دايما مشكلتي مع الاخبار المتعلقه بالامير
هاري انه هو بيتحدث دائما عن رغبته في
الخصوصيه واهتمام الصحافه في والكلام هذا
كله والان طبعا رافع قضيه والكلام هذا كله
وفي نفس الوقت هو صراحه اعطانا كميه
تفاصيل عن حياته الشخصيه في السنوات
الاخيره اكثر مما كنا نحتاج اصلا اننا
نعرف
صح انا كتير حبيت السؤال ساره لانه بالفعل
هيك ما فينا ننكر انه الصحافه ببريطانيا
ممكن تكون صحافه متطفله يعني التاريخ
دايما عم بيعيد نفسه يعني فينا نقول
الصحافه الصفراء عم نحكي عن التابلت انه
هيك بتعمل عاده
بتستحصل على المعلومات بطريقه ما فيها نوع
من الادب بطريقه
مش مقبوله لانه بطريقه ممكن وصفه بغير
شرعيه ولكن
اصلا المؤسسه الاعلاميه اعتذرت سابقا عن
انها فعلا تجسست هاتفيا او على الهواتف
يعني ايه
عندهم سوابق وقدت كمان احدى الحوادث
لاغلاق يعني صحيفه معروفه ومرموقه جدا فما
فينا نقول انه الصحافه بريطانيا ما بتقوم
بمثل هذه الاعمال المشيله ولكن لما بدنا
نحكي عن الامير هاري وعن انه قديش هو
بناشد بانه بطالب انه يكون في عنده حريه
شخصيه وما بحب الناس تتبعوا ولكن
الدعايه اللي عملها لنفسه ولا زوجته بعد
اطلاق كتابه هذا يعني هذا الموضوع وحده
يعني كافي لحتى يكون ماده دسمه للصحافه
فهو اول شيء قالوا اليوم بامتثاله قدام
المحكمه اللي تغيب عنه مثل ما انت تفضلتي
وقلتي امس انه قال انه الصحافه هون صورت
لاله صوره معينه يعني لعبوا هم بالاشياء
اللي هو ممكن يقوم فيها بالحياه لما كان
عمره 20 سنه كان شاب طايش فصورته الصحافه
على شكل الامير
السكير الامير اللي يتعاطى المخدرات ولكن
اذا بدنا نحكي بالمنطق هو قام فعليا
بهالاشياء كيف حصلت الصحافه على هذه
المعلومات هيدا يلي هلا عم نتناقش فيه هل
بطريقه شرعيه او غير شرعيه ولكن هو هلا
حاليا عم بيترفع يعني عم بيدافع عن حاله
قدام موكل يعني قدام محامي اللقب تبعوله
اللي قائم بالمدافعه الموكل عنا شركه
ميرور
للمطبوعات ام جي ان اسمه
يعني هذا الوحش وحش وحش المحاميه هون
بالبلد فاول شيء قال له انه عن قضيه
التنصت فراح يكون في ثغرات مش منتبه
للامير هاري انا برايي خاصه انه هو بيقول
انه تنصتوا على مكالماته الخاصه على هاتفه
الجوال سنه 96 ولكن هو بنفس الوقت بيقول
بانه بهذا العام لم يكن يملك هاتفا جوانا
لا يعني صراحه اصلا يعني بقول لك بعد
كتابه زي ما ذكرتي يعني هو تحدث مثلا عن
اعضاءه الخاصه يعني اكثر من عشر مرات جد
سيرتها في الكتاب تفاصيل ما كنا محتاجين
ابدا انه نحن نعرفها بس اذا حابين نضيف
لهذا الكلام والجدل الكلام من الكلام اللي
هو قاله هو كمان هاجم الاعلام طبعا بشكل
صريح وقال انه هو في القاع وهذا هجوم
دائما مستمر عنده ولكن اليوم كمان في
الشهاده قال الحكومه ايضا في القاع
الحكومه البريطانيه في القاع لما تيجي من
امير بريطاني بارز يعني هذا يعتبر ابدا
شيء غير مسبوق وكسر للقواعد يعني
ساره انت بتقري افكار انا كان بدي اتطرق
لهذه النقطه يلي هي كتير كتير مهمه هو
صحيح يعني داخل بهالمعركه القانونيه الى
جانب مئه شخصيه ولكن هل شخصيات يلي داخلين
بهالمعمعه هايدي هن شخصيات بارزه بعالم
الفن ولكن ممنوع تابعين فهو بالترتيب
الخامس بالعائله المالكيه فهو شخصيه
مرموقه وهو فرد من افراد العائله المالكه
لما بيحكي اليوم وبيقول انه
الحكومه في عندها تواطئ مع الصحافه
ببريطانيا وهي تلعب دور يعني الشيطان
الاخرس هون في هون في خطوره لانه هو هو
اللي طلب من
المحكمه انه يتوجهوا له باسم الامير هاري
وليس دوقس هذا كان خياره الشخصي فانت
موجود كامير فما بحق لك التطرق حتى لو كان
هالشي هذا
صحيح وانا ما عم بنفع عن يعني طريقه
التعامل بين الصحافه الصفراء التابلود
بريطانيا وبين الحكومه ولكن بما انه هو لا
يزال يحمل اللقب الملكي لازم يكون عنده
انتباه اكثر لما بده يتطرق لمواضيع شائكه
جدا الصحافه البريطانيه يمكن واحده من
التعليقات اللي قالتها انه في مئه مشهور
داخلين في هذه القضيه لكن الامير هاري هو
الوحيد اللي محول الموضوع لانه حلقات من
برنامج اوبرا طبعا المقدمه الشريره واللي
كان عندها كثير دراما في الحلقات اللي
بتقدمها وطبعا هو عمل معاها مقابله هو
وميجان وعمل يعني عملوا قمه كانت البدايه
الانطلاقه للجرامه طيب جوزيلين انا بشكرك
جدا طبعا احنا راح نستمر في المتابعه نحنا
بنتكلم انه احنا غدا ايضا تستمر
المحاكمه كانت معنا من لندن الكاتبه
الصحفيه جوسيلين اللي شكرا لك
ويلي اليوم الثالث على التوالي لازال اسم
اللاعب الفرنسي كريم بنزيما ترند على
المنصات مهاجم ريال مدريد اللي كان اعلن
ناديه عن نهايه رحلته مع من بعد 14 موسم
واشتعلت التكهنات والاخبار عن وجهه
القادمه انحسمت التكهنات عن مصيره اليوم
متاكدت بالاعلان عن انضمام بنزيما لنادي
الاتحاد السعودي وتم توقيع عقد معالي
ثلاثه مواسم وكان بنزيما لاعب يوم الاحد
اخر مبارياته مع نادي ريال مدريد ضد
اتلتيكو بلباوند من منافسات الجوله
الاخيره من الليغا واللي انتهت بالتعادل
وسجل خلال المباراه بنزيما اخر اهدافه مع
ريال مدريد ومن الساعات عقد في النادي في
مدريد مؤتمر صحفي او عقد هناك مؤتمر صحفي
وداعي لبنزيما
[تصفيق]
ريال مدريد فلورنت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وس
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم انا عد
والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في امان الله
[موسيقى]